what's up everyone welcome back to the
supper suite at tiff 2022 i am very
happy to be talking with the team behind
i'm not just saying this because you're
sitting here one of my favorite movies
that i've seen at the festival thus far
it's the team behind brother
congratulations your work is exceptional
and you for
i don't just like blow my mind
i seriously don't know how you do this
uh clement let's start with you here can
you do us the honor of giving a brief
synopsis of brother for anybody out
there who does not know what your movie
ends um
a brother is about a jamaican
canadian family living in a place called
scarborough and it's about family
community music and love
i was reading that this is the fastest
script you've ever written what was it
about the source material that kind of
just had it pour out of you like that
well you know when i read the script it
just felt very very
familiar to me i was i was deeply moved
by it you know it was about a immigrant
family um i'm from jamaica grew up here
in
in toronto um and
they've felt like my family if the mom
felt like my mom the siblings felt like
my siblings and so you know i
i absolutely had to make it and so once
i had the rights to the scripts um it
was the fastest scripts
that i wrote
ever written because it just poured out
at me just felt so easy you know felt
very very familiar i was also reading
the press notes that you described it as
a bookend with your first film so what
is something you're able to accomplish
on brother that first feature you would
say like i cannot believe that i would
grow and evolve to the point that i'd be
able to accomplish that well i think i
think with my first film rude um you
know i was the star of the movie what i
mean by that is i pour everything into
it you know and with this film i wanted
it to be to have the actors and the
movie be the star you know and and
that's a difference i think okay so now
i'm going to throw a big old group
question whoever wants to jump in go for
it but but given what he just described
what is something about him as an
actor's director that makes him stand
out from anyone else you've ever worked
with that maybe facilitates the
opportunity to deliver performances like
this you know it's interesting that he
said he was comfortable making us the
star i think that's very truthful
um he's not invasive
the way he gives notes if he even gives
you notes is that it's very um
quiet it's usually on point
not wordy he's a man of very few words
um he doesn't intrude on a moment if a
moment is happening he'll let it breathe
he'll let it have its life that it needs
if it takes a little while
uh
i just felt very very comfortable with
clement um i told him i was like i think
you spoiled me for
other directors just because you know
it's it's interesting when you just know
that your director implicitly trusts you
he trusts you with the work he hired you
he knows he hired the person he wants
and then he trusts you and lets you live
it's beautiful i've
i've been very fortunate to work with a
number of directors that create a safe
working environment and a safe creative
space and clement is certainly
part of that list he he creates
an environment in which you feel
entirely safe
and comfortable
to be
entirely vulnerable
and
due to the subject matter that is you
know very present in this movie that
requires that from everybody you know
and and he created a space that we all
felt very safe and very comfortable and
i've said it to you a number of times
but we we deeply appreciate you man
because without without that space it's
not it's not necessarily possible to
achieve any sort of truthful
interpretation of the words on on the
page so
we appreciate you man thank you i love
that so much
thank you
uh lamar and aaron so for the two of you
i imagine there's a whole bunch of prep
that goes into developing this
relationship before you hit set but is
there any specific quality of their
connection to each other that you
weren't able to find until you were on
set like actually working with each
other that's an interesting question i
mean
i truthfully i mean working with aaron
was such a pleasure and i truthfully
don't think that there was really
anything that we
didn't discover for ourselves that was
necessary
to bring to these characters you know uh
we didn't have a lot of time in prep
really so it was sort of like a crash
course you know we took time you know
obviously offset and you know we sat
down and you know we were just very
vulnerable with each other we're honest
and we shared a lot of our life
experience together and i think that
naturally connected us in a way that was
uh intentful and it was
purposeful for the relationship between
michael and francis you know um
just to give like context to what you
were saying like this is like maybe on
like the first or second day having ever
met each other so it's like hi my name
is aaron hi my name is lamar so this
happened in my childhood yeah this this
happened in my adolescent years this
happened in my you know formative years
you know right what was your experience
like growing up what was it like in your
neighborhood what your community right
like at school you know what was what
was the environment like how did you
know it how did you grow up how your
mother like how you know there's just so
many things that we just shared that was
necessary that we needed to share in
order for us to really
create that bond and that connection
that
is you know a large part of the film my
head is exploding with questions right
now ken i'll go to you next because i
was reading in the uh press notes that
you you described working with lamar as
like you were not acting when you were
on set so what is it about him as a
scene partner that gives you that kind
of feeling when you're on set i mean
aside from his talent obviously um and
his craftsmanship uh i think that
we have a lot of chemistry so that's
always a blessing you don't always know
that you know you don't know you're
going to come to set and naturally have
chemistry with someone but i think
ultimately it was lamar's openness
um
willingness to really
go to the depths that were required to
tell such an authentic story um his love
of the project and his character
and
and that that goes to offset too i mean
like we also had conversations and
really got to know each other which made
me feel really safe to trust him like i
think that's what it is especially when
you play a love interest right like
if you don't really know the person that
well going into the project me
personally i i want to feel safe at the
end of the day and lamar really made me
feel safe to
ultimately fall in love through our
characters and
it was a
joy working with him for that reason and
something that i will always hold really
close to my heart i love hearing that so
much all right this gives me a good
segue i'm actually going to read
something so marcia stephanie i need to
ask you about something that i read in
the production notes that like this this
is the type of stuff i love hearing
about but it said that an entire book
can be written about how you tackled
your character but also about how you
wrapped your arms around the cast and
the crew of brother what do you
prioritize when you hit any set this set
any other set that you're on to create
that feeling for the people around you
you know a part of the job as an actor
is to go into this space right or this
community this this
character and immediately
have to convince people that you have
relationships
with these other actors um that are
that's
that has a history
that has like all the feelings that you
put into these intimate relationships
it's part of our job right so we we have
a shorthand and we also are in
insanely open people because you have to
be you have to like walk into a room and
have your heart wide open and just like
okay come in because we only have a
month to shoot this thing right um
what's really
beautiful about this group of people is
that
there's no re there was no resistance to
that
um sometimes you meet resistance
sometimes you're trying to be someone's
mom
or you know best friend or what have you
and you meet a little bit of resistance
between the character and the the person
but i think these guys were so open um
i also think
i personally the minute i find out that
i'm playing someone's mom i start
treating them like they're my child
whether they like it or not okay so
i
wrote my boys notes
i gave them presents
and they were my sons and as far as i'm
concerned they're my sons for the rest
of time because now it's a permanent
film so sorry guys but
i am your mom now i have another
question for you because i wanna i'm
basically gonna ask you for your secret
sauce right now because you consistently
pick projects that like have something
important to say really this is why i
keep inviting whatever movie you're in
back to the interview
every time i see you what is something
that remains consistent between every
project that you pick something you need
to see but then also what is something
about brother that gave you the
opportunity to uh scratch a creative
itch that no other project in the past
let you do
the
very specific exploration
of an immigrant mom
who is struggling
not just financially but emotionally
that the idea that um you know
in our community we don't necessarily
have therapy right we don't go to
therapists doctors therapists
and so
it's about
what happens to a woman like this
when something so major occurs in her
life that affects her on such an
emotional
just devastating level um how she falls
apart physically and emotionally but
then also who is there to hold her up
and i've seen a lot of that in my family
um i think i talked to you about uh
before about quiet women the women whose
voices i am this is what attracts me to
these kinds of projects i am trying to
bring
you know awareness put a voice um give
voice to these quiet women that i saw
the entire time i was growing up
who aren't necessarily looking for that
really
um
but they don't talk to anybody about
their problems
uh
so i feel like i have like a duty
to
illuminate them and show them as human
and and multi-dimensional and also not
just show their trauma but show their
joy
you know show their love and
all the things that come into
these quiet sort of hidden
women you make a big impression with
those intentions i love it so much um i
remember you telling me that but also
one specific thing you've told me once
and i bring this question back often as
you were telling me once about like a
hostess tray and so
so now i ask everyone what is like a
seemingly silly thing about the process
of making a film that you wish you had
the nerve to ask about earlier on like
when you're when you're a first timer on
all right everything's going on around
you
i'm like i'll never forget that
um aaron coming your way now and there
was there was something that i picked up
in the press notes for you too it
described you as someone who could be
deeply immersed in their character but
also always accessible and that can be a
very difficult thing to balance like for
yourself and the people around you so
what is the key to being able to juggle
both
that's a really great question and i
wish i knew the answer i i feel like
you know
whenever i
am fortunate enough to be welcomed on
board a project
my objective
remains the same my objective is to
attempt to be as truthful and honest and
authentic as i possibly can be
um and and i almost set the objective of
achieving it perfectly knowing that's
not achievable because that way i'm
never
i'm never satisfied and i'm continuously
reaching something that is trying to
reach something that is unobtainable
so so from the very first
day that i
get the offer to the very last day on
set when i rap i'm constantly trying to
reach something that i know i can't
reach and that keeps me sort of
learning from all of these wonderful
people
learning from this incredibly phenomenal
filmmaker
and and and learning from the words on
the script um
and and just try yeah just trying to
be in the
you know pursue that you know that
that's why i guess
i guess that's what it is i feel like
that mentality can help anyone out there
whether they're in an artistic field or
just anything for that matter you like
that thought um i'm gonna have to let
you guys go soon i could talk to you for
forever but i have to ask about a couple
of upcoming projects and ken i don't
even even know if this is true you
probably can't tell me anything you know
where i'm going with this i'm gonna i'm
gonna give you some currency to try to
convince you to give me an honest answer
i wore my fear street shoes for you
today
normally i'd find a roundabout way to
try to get someone to give me an answer
that they actually can give but i can't
are we getting more fear street that
includes you
honestly
i love your shoes
and
hopefully we can discuss that
soon but i really do love your shoes i
will take that i'll take it i know i
have to roll with that for now um here's
something you can't talk about the the
mcu
there are so many mcu projects out there
right now but what is something about
getting the opportunity to join such a
big franchise that's so important to so
many people out there through blade in
particular is there anything about that
character that story and the people
you're working with on that set that
makes you think i'm glad this is my
first
i think i think it's just
that the mcu is something that from a
very young age i've always
looked to and
been inspired by and been excited by
um and at times been empowered by you
know particularly with movies like black
panther and things like this so i think
for me honestly it's just
i'm just tremendously grateful um
and uh
just abundantly thankful to even
have been considered to to become part
of that family so yeah
having seen your past performances i am
not surprised you were considered and
got that role
last one speaking speaking of last you
know where i'm going with this the last
of us
a lot a lot of hardcore fans out there
that are very very excited about that
series what can you tease about the show
that you think is going to like maybe
give them exactly what they want in an
adaptation but also something that might
surprise them that the show has that
maybe they didn't realize an adaptation
needs yeah well you know the people
behind the show are avid fans so
they definitely
are taking this ip and making sure that
the fans are really getting what they
want you know adaptions are always
difficult but i think with the team
behind this uh they really care about
the material and the project and the
characters and um i think the the fans
are really gonna gonna love the show i'm
gonna squeeze in one more brother
question don't see anyone wrapping me up
just because the last time we spoke it
was for the hate you give and you told
me about a george tillman junior's uh
monitor dance and now i need to know
every director's monitor dance like when
you all can sense that uh clement's
loving one of your takes what does he do
behind the monitor that says to you like
i am crushing this right now
marcia stephanie's right he's a man of
very few words so like the most you'll
like the most you'll get is like you'll
just hear someone go all right got it
got it
got it and like
all of us would always be like are you
sure are you sure you're sure and he's
like hey got it we got it yeah
so yeah
i'm like testing my limits now
i'll let you close this out here even
with all of your experience and all of
your growth as a filmmaker over the
years there's always more room to grow
so what is something new you experience
on the set of brother that added a new
like tool to your directing toolkit so
to speak that you are eager to apply on
your next film well i think you know um
but first of all i i was given this
given a gift with this talented group of
group of actors um and
for me you know when i was younger i
thought i had to be like a
actor's kind of you know acting teacher
but now i just i hire the right people i
give them the space to work
um and and i trust them
and you know and and that's what i've
learned on this show
just don't mess it up with your
direction
there's so many more questions you guys
spoil me your answers are too good your
movies are too good congratulations
thank you for coming by the supper suite
enjoy your premiere today thank you
excellent everyone out there thank you
keep an eye out for brother we'll see
you soon with more tiff 2022 interviews
you